[音楽]
ん
goo er
[拍手]
19歳の時に初めて来日して私は本当のビラを主人になりました
私の泉津もみんなヴィラル詩人でシーン
下ラウ氏の国籍を持っていますし本当のブラウ主人になったという言い方は奇妙に
聞こえるかもしれません
例えば
本当の日本人と言い方をされたら皆さんはどういう人を涼しますか
皆さんは日本人としてのアイデンティティについて考えたことはありますか
人の民族的なアイデンティティを決定するのは
大谷の民族的なルーツなのでしょうか
もしかしたら外見
育てられた場所の文化
某国語としておけている言葉
私の場合は私のブラを主人としてのアイデンティティーを強めてのは私の泉津が話して
た
ブラウ氏語の習得でした
自分の先祖の言葉を話せない人や民族は世界中にスカンクスなくはありません
例えば先住民族少数民族移民
しかし独立国家を持ってその国の中でダンス派民族で言いながら自分の先祖の言葉が
話せない
民族は世界でば突くしかありません
その一つの中はベラルーシ人です
ベラる主の言語仕様の状況を簡単にススメすると人口の8割以上はブラウ氏人なのに
ベラウ死亡日常のことばとして使っているのは号パーセントいいかだと拙速されてい
ます
9割以上はロシア語で話しています
しかしその中は53%はベラ牛子を自分の峰号として認識しています
言葉を話せなくてもその言葉を自分の防護として思う思うというのはレア牛人の特徴的
な考え方だと思います
ん
皆さん想像してみてください
もし第二次世界対戦の後
日本でアメリカによる占領が続いていて
英語は日本のこういう子になったと言うがそうの世界を想像してみてください
テレビつけても英語ばかり
あー外で歩いている日本人の皆普通に英語で喋っています
あー学校職場得に言っても英語です
英語が流暢に話せるっていう理想的な世界だなと思う人もいるかもしれませんが
即に見えない反面があります
日本語という言葉もう方も誰も話せません
田舎に住んでいる高齢者はまだ日本語で会話していますけれどもその孫と子供の世代は
日本語
時代遅れ田舎の言葉話だし死にかけている言語で話すって何の意味があるの
という考え方を持つ人はダースが
になったらこういう世界は本当に理想的なのでしょうか
現在のヴィラ牛はまったくもってこういう状況です
ベラルーシーの
状況を持って説明するために通してベラウ詩人は自分の線図の言葉を話せないという
理由を皆さんにもっと深く理解していただけるために少し歴史を説明する必要があると
思います
ベラル c 事をロシア語の関係の
転換期になったのは18世紀末に行われたロシア帝国による植民地化でしたん
当時のヴィラロシ子のあみしロシア人と呼ばれ
もともと老主人だったというプロパガンダがロシア帝国の正式な
団はでした
ベラ牛子はをロシア語の方言とされ
教育の面でも宗教の面でも同化政策が実施されました
ロシア帝国の時代が終わってベラルーシは装備と連邦の一つの装備度社会主義強国に
なりました
ドレンの民族政策では当時の政権に通って
民族自決主義はどとても危険なものとして考えられました
それで
それぞれの民族今日は高校の中で
ナショナリズムの革命が起きないように
銀地の知識人が抹殺されプロ主人も含めて
老子あご下進みました特に
プロ主人に文化的にや言語的に近い
ヴィラル主人とウクライナ人に対して厳しい
同化政策が実施されました
そしてそれが他して一時的にベラルーシ豪華制作が始まりましたが
国民投票によってベラルーシ語に加えあロシア語も紅葉号の地位を得て
ベラウ仕事の平等の木や形を与えられました
その結果はヴィラル死後の立場アッパ
軽視されて
ユネスコの
消滅危険度評価によって全五尺な危険にあると評価されました
しかし現在はもっと
状況が発覚してきて
今
ヴィラルしで
世代間のゲーム合計省はほぼ行われていません
ということは
子どもたちはブラウ主語を自分の防護をとして取得することはほぼありません
私はを生まれてから
周りにホーブいつもをロシア語が聞こえました
ん
私の両親の第一言語はベラ牛子だったんですけど図鑑
あ家庭以外の環境はほぼ全てロシア語だったし
ロシア語を話す完璧なソ連人通して生活していて私をロシア語で育てました
いなくにある父の時間
デフ休みとか夏休みを過ごしてて
生きているブラウ氏後に触れておばあちゃんとおじいちゃんが話してた
ヴィラル4号でも自分で自然に会話できるようになりました
しかし
街に戻るとすぐにロシア語に切り替えて
ベラウシボが使えるバーは週に数回しかなかったです
それは学校のペラ牛語の授業でした
しかし学校の同期生とベラ牛語で話すはても思わなかったです
嫌ではなかったのですが
田舎者なのと馬鹿されるだろうという恐怖感があったからです
学校卒業してベラ牛の首都であるミンスク
という街の大学に入学して純正で初めて
日常でベラ牛語を話す
同じ年代の
一人の方に出会えました
本当に衝撃を受けて感動の出会いでした
こんなに美ラウシュ5に対する
偏見がある社会の中でベラウ死亡普通に話せてすごい雪があるなぁとその時思いました
当時は大学の寮の仲間から
ベラルし後初めてブラウシグの音楽や学校で教え
教えられてないベラルーシ語の現代文学作品とか
初夏してもらって
裏牛子話すブラウ主人と出会いが増えてきて
自分が17歳まあでは本当に孤立させられた島に住んでたのかなーっていう気持ちでし
た
私は juke さん時に
来日して
自分の文化や言語を大事にしている
世界中からの留学生に出会いました
そしてベラ牛子に対する偏見がない環境に囲まれてきたおかげでベラルーシ語を自分の
本当の母語にしたいと決心しました
最初は自分の家族から始めて今
一時帰国するときにどこでもいつも
ベラウ州語で話しています
自分の娘も阿部らを主人としてそういうアイデンティティをモデルためにいつもブラウ
氏語で話しかけています
自分の姻族の本当の歴史とか文化とかの知識を取得したら
民族的なプライドを持てるようになって自信がついて
そして民族的なアイデンティティが強くなる
と思います
そうなると誇りに思っている言語
を習得して先祖の言語ですね
で次世代のレーションしたくなるでしょう
近しいん
私は
でらーロシ子からヴィラルシー語に変換するときに
後ろ向きになる面もありましたん
例えば私は親戚から批判的な態度を設けたことがありますし
自分のおばあちゃんの私は
ヴィラ牛子の本を読んでいる様子を見ると
こんな誰も入らない言語勉強して時間の無駄にしないでと言われたこともあります
もう一つの章兵器は
国からの差別です
峰号での教育峰号での治療
峰号での就職という
ベラ牛子ノア車の基本的なキャンディが侵害されています
ヴィラル4号を自分の日常の言葉にするという選択肢を選ぶ人たちは毎日
社会の偏見と自分の一種との闘いながらからしています
例えば
私もヴィラ牛の病院で診察とかを受ける時に私の言葉をちゃんと伝わるのか
どうしてブラウ氏語で話していますかどうもはて聞かれたら
また説明しないといけないなぁと思って
毎回緊張感とうんざりした気持ちを感じています
そういう時だけブラウそういう時だけやロシア語で話せばいいのではないかという誘惑
な気持ちになることは少なくありません
しかし寺牛子でどこでもいつでも話すという選択肢を選んだ私はその道から外れたら
自分ではなくなる自分らしくなくなるのではないかと思います
私は来日の大きい犬のおかげで
自分の先祖の言語に目を向けて
ベラウ神として強いアイデンティティを持てるようになったのですか
実はよく日本人から私の民族的なアイデンティティが音が割れています
例えば道を歩くときに
ロシア人だと言われてい
あしますし
人と初めて挨拶する時に
立っちゃなと申しますと言っても何回もそういう人と会っても
勝手にロシア語二に立ちアナと呼ばれてします
もちろん世界のすべての文化民俗国の好投
みんな絶対に勉強すべきということではありません
でも
私たちは人と出会うときに
外見から判断して
すぐに
人種的文化的なステッカーを張ってしまう傾向があります
そしてそうなったらもう意識的にその人の民族的なプライド
自尊感情を傷つけて
自分が気づかないうちに差別的な態度してしまったという経験が多分ほぼ皆ある
でしょう
私は
あの本当のビラー詩人として尊敬している二人を紹介したいと思います
こちらの方は本当のブラウン主人です
50の方もそうです
2人ともグラウ集合場所でグラを主人としての強いアイデンティティを持っています
人の民族的なアイデンティティは人が自分で決めることです
そして同じアイデンティティを保っている
集団からの承認によって
決定されることだと思います
担任が押し付けることではないと思います
で
そうしたらベラルーシ語が話さない暮らし人は
ヴィラ牛人ではないのでしょうか
もう一論争ではありませんブラウ死後小平を主人としてのアイデンティティを持ってい
たら
ベラ牛子なんですけれどもどうかされやすい
ブラウ詩人になるリスクがあると思います
言葉って銀後は
ただの音
音節の組み合わせ文法的な規則
だけではなく
我々のすべての文化
例えばせいか世界観
人間関係民族料理
子供にをたう子守をたーーー
すべてが
全てのモノ子物事がモンゴとの密接なつながりがあると思います
言語が絶滅するときに一つのとても大きな世界が消えてしまうでしょ
コートバーは民族の証というとても印象に残った言葉があります
この言葉を私は聞いたのはある日
平取町二風谷のアイヌ文化
資料館で流れていたドキュメンタリー微量でアイヌ民族のせい時間
文化研究者だった
萱野茂氏がおっしゃった言葉です
言葉は民族の証
つまり銀後は
民族の
存在の証拠
民族の根本です
もしなりに権力を持っている
ダースほど水子がいたら勝訴であるものは
希薄させられる恐れがあると思います
そうなると
4秒どな民族間関係に抵抗するために言語はとても重要な道具だと思います
奪われた
言葉
をも手に取り戻すのは復興するのは
本当に何世代か時間かかる
とっても複雑なプロセスです
自分の言語や文化を守るために毎日
社会とそして自分自身と戦わなくてもいいという日本人のような民族はどうても幸運だ
と思います
皆さんにとってはビラー氏の話はどう感じるかもしれませんが
ここ日本にも変則的なアイデンティティニーズ悩みがある人がいます
ここの文化を経験するために世界に目を向けるのは大事ですが
まずは
すぐそばにある異文化の理解が重要だと思います
ちー民族の言語や文化を尊敬している人は
たーーーー民族の言語や文化を尊敬して理解できるでしょ
そうなると
民族的なアイデンティティの悩みと差別がない
出走的な世界になるのではないか
じゃ君ありがとうございました
[拍手]